is real it is flying and we are gonna
have it here in the United States in the
next few years this is it the cormorant
a flying vehicle that could not only
save American lives on battlefields a
world away but also on highways right
here at home there's the concept of the
Golden Hour that in order to maximize
survivability and an accident you need
to get to that victim and get that
victim evacuated into medical attention
within an hour the idea for a vehicle
that can go where helicopters can't was
born out of the 2006 Israel Hezbollah
war where it took on average five and a
half hours to evacuate wounded Israeli
soldiers one is the ground to air fire
the other is that because of the
physical limitations of the helicopters
rotor it cannot land in a mountainous or
obstacle rich area the cormorant is
currently being designed and tested in
Israel with keen interest and support
from the Israeli military but the
long-term plan is for production to move
to the United States and for both
pilotless and piloted models to be
available for military and civilian
emergencies Disaster Response nuclear
biological chemical decontamination a
dirty bomb in the city button against
the wall of a building and rescuing
people and so on this aircraft can do
all of that because it doesn't have the
overhead rotors urban aeronautics says
it hopes to be producing the cormorant
here in the US by 2022 the company calls
it a win-win for everyone Israeli
technology US production and potentially
countless lives saved